foreign
[Music]
hello my name is Neil Weingarten I'm a
field application scientist with 10x
genomics and I'm going to be discussing
some practical considerations and best
practices for single cell and spatial
transcriptomics
traditional gene expression assays have
relied mainly on bulk analysis which
give you a general idea of the
expression happening in a tissue but
lacks cellular or spatial resolution
single cell gene expression assays allow
researchers to characterize individual
cell types within a tissue providing
much greater resolution and
understanding of the underlying
complexity of the tissue
now with spatial gene expression methods
researchers can map the spatial pattern
of gene expression
integrating these two data sets provides
key insights into how tissue functions
by combining single cell data with
spatial data researchers can now address
a wide range of biological questions
including refining cell atlases
discovering new cell types with
anatomical location
characterizing tissue and cell
architecture across development and
disease and identifying pathological
processes
I'd like to start with a very brief
introduction to both single cell and
spatial transcriptomics approaches
in order to study transcriptomics at the
Single Cell level it's critical to
partition the cells into discrete
reactions in order to isolate and tag
the transcripts from each individual
cell
the more partitions that can be created
the greater the level of heterogeneity
that can be assessed in our approach
individual cells are isolated into
discrete aqueous drops within an oil
Emulsion these droplets also include a
bar-coded gel bead that provides tags
that are incorporated into the resultant
cdna so the transcripts can be mapped
back onto the cell of origin
typically up to ten thousand individual
cells are captured and profiled
we call these droplets gel beads in
emulsions or gems
the gel beads act as an oligon delivery
tool the beads provide the necessary
reverse transcription primers that allow
for creation of cdna from the MRNA
transcripts released when the cell lysis
within the drug
these oligos contain a polydt sequence
that will hybridize the poly8 tail of
the MRNA as well as a barcode which
identifies the cell of origin
a unique molecular identifier or Umi
allows for the initial transcriptive
origin to be identified providing an
accurate assessment of the number of
initial copies within the cell
a microscopic picture of one of these
gems is seen here normally such a
picture cannot be taken because the cell
lyses too fast however we've changed a
few things in order to get this image as
you can see there is a discrete droplet
isolated from the rest of the solution
in which we have a gel bead and an
individual single cell
this is the key to obtaining single cell
transcriptomes
the generation of tens of thousands of
such droplets allows for many cells to
be profiled individually
the resultant sequencing ready library
from a single cell transcriptomics
experiment contains the barcode sequence
Umi and a cdna insert sequence that
allow for mapping of individual
transcripts onto a reference
transcriptome and the association of
that transcript with the cell of origin
in a spatial transcriptomics approach
mrnas are captured while maintaining the
relative initial position within the
tissue the resultant transcriptomic
information can be overlaid back onto
the image of the originating tissue
section to provide a high degree of
spatial resolution of the initial
transcripts
in our approach a similar oligo
construct is used again with a poly a
tail to capture the MRNA this time the
barcode provides the X Y coordinates of
the spot on the slide
again a Umi sequence allows for accurate
assessment of the initial number of
copies within each spot
s are a raid and hexagonal pattern with
each spot having a diameter of 55
microns and a center to Center Pitch of
100 microns
the total capture area is 6.5
millimeters by 6.5 millimeters squared
multiple capture areas on a single slide
allow for multiple tissue sections to be
profiled
tissue sections typically on the order
of 10 to 20 microns thick are placed
onto a capture region containing the
arrayed oligos that I just discussed
the tissue is stained imaged and then
permeabilized to release the RNA for
capture
the RNA is reverse transcribed on the
slide and the resulted cdna is released
in order to create a sequencing Library
the resultant sequencing ready library
from spatial transcriptomics experiments
look essentially the same as from a
single cell transcriptomic library
it contains the barcode sequence Umi and
cdna insert that allows for mapping onto
the reference transcriptome this time
the transcripts are associated with the
spot of origin
now that we've discussed the underlying
Technologies let's quickly review a few
practical experimental design
considerations
many researchers first embarking on a
single cell experiment often ask about
the appropriate cell number and
sequencing depth required for an
experiment the truth is this is a
balance between the question being asked
the complexity of the sample and the
sequencing budget
a more complex tissue for which a
researcher wishes to detect a small
subset of cells will require more cells
to be profiled
more cells will in turn cost more to
sequence as such researchers need to
balance all of these aspects there are
no quick answers here but tools such as
the how many cells calculator from the
strategy lab
the staff at your core service provider
or the technical staff at the technology
partner will be able to help you with
this
the depth at which you sequence your
single cell experiment will in turn be
related to the overall complexity of the
transcriptome of the cells larger cells
like cancer cells with more initial RNA
content may require deeper sequencing
depths than smaller cells with less RNA
for example an immune cell
as with single cell gene expression
libraries tissue complexity also impacts
the required sequencing depth for a
spatial transcriptomics approach
if the tissue placed onto the slide is
less complex as seen here with the human
brain section on the right it will
require less sequencing to reach a
similar saturation level than a more
complex sample such as the mouse brain
section on the left
of course this is not to say that human
brains are less complex than most brains
however in any given 6.5 millimeter by
6.5 millimeter square this happens to be
the case
another common question relates to the
number of replicates that need to be run
fortunately these approaches are very
robust they are very reproducible at the
technical level
here we see a representation of the same
sample run 16 different times for a
single cell transcriptomics experiment
these were run over two different
microfluidics chips
it's fairly apparent the overall
signatures being seen here are highly
reproducible
that same data presented in a more
quantitative fashion shows that the
technical replicates from the same
Source material are highly reproducible
each of these pairwise comparisons
having r squared values above 0.99
looking at individual genes of Interest
also shows a high degree of similarity
in technical replicates in this case
even across different chips which was
therefore separate runs
here we're looking at biological rather
than technical replicants
two sections of an E18 Mouse brain were
profiled separately
in such a case we would expect a
biological variation to be relatively
minimal indeed you can see a high degree
of reproducibility with r squared values
above 0.95
taken in total I tend to recommend that
your experimental budget be used to test
true biological replicates separate mice
or separate patient samples rather than
focusing on more technical replicates as
these Technologies really are quite
reproducible
spatial transcriptomics approaches are
also highly reproducible
it's not really possible to do a true
biological or sorry a true technical
replicate with this technology because
the tissue section really is consumed
during the process so here what we have
instead are two serial sections of a
mouse brain
for these two sections the software
identified 12 distinct clusters of spots
they were identified on the basis of
transcriptional similarity
the spots are colored on the basis of
which cluster each spot was associated
with
and you can see the remarkable
similarity between these two sections
with very very similar patterns existing
if we were to look at the expression of
a specific Gene in this case myelin
basic protein or MBP it is again evident
how similar the patterns are across
these two sections so taken as a total
each of these Technologies was really
quite reproducible at the technical
level
now that I've talked about some of the
experimental design considerations I'd
like to talk about considerations for
sample preparation
in order to ensure the success of a
single cell or spatial transcriptomics
experiment the quality of the sample
must be optimized a good quality sample
is critical to overall performance
when working with single cells it's
critical that the tissue be fully
dissociated into a single cell
suspension this not only ensures that
the microfluidics in the system will not
become clogged but it also ensures that
each partition will have a chance to
capture a single cell rather than a
clump or aggregate of more than one cell
viability is also Paramount
dead and dying cells will also be
captured and this potentially leads to
spending some of your sequencing budget
towards cells that are not really of
Interest
perhaps even more problematic dead and
dying cells are fragile and they can
lyse very easily releasing RNA into the
ambient environment and this creates a
background noise that is hard to
distinguish from the true signal of a
cell
it is therefore critical to treat cells
gently wash them gently and produce a
high viability single cell sample
the removal of debris and other cellular
Aggregates will help to prevent clogging
of the microfluidic channels as well as
reduce the noise in the transcriptomic
data we recommend filtering or straining
these cells
accurate cell counting will be critical
to providing a consistent cell Target
number
automated counters can make this process
a lot more easy and reproducible
finally the cell storage and the
efficient processing of those cells are
key to ensuring that the viability as
well as transcriptional signature of the
cells are not impacted
our website
support.10xgenomics.com
has a cell preparation guide which you
can download and discusses each of these
topics in even more detail
similarly when working with spatial
transcriptomics approaches it is
important that the tissue be preserved
in this case Frozen in such a way that
both histology and RNA quality are
preserved
I'm again we have a demonstrated
protocol available on our website at
support.10xgenomics.com
that guide discusses all of the key
concepts of tissue preparation
some of the key topics are RNA quality
assessment tissue freezing embedding as
well as sectioning and placement of the
tissues onto the slides
the specific method of freezing is
critical as it ensures maintenance of
tissue morphology while protecting RNA
integrity in general we rep we recommend
a rapid but very even freezing method
specifically
isopantane in a liquid nitrogen bath
which prevents tissue cracking during
the freezing process
Frozen tissues are embedded into OCT for
proper sectioning and placement onto the
slide
as I said rapid freezing is critical to
maintain that morphology and RNA quality
however directly freezing in liquid
nitrogen can be problematic as can cause
tissue cracking the low boiling point of
liquid nitrogen causes rapid expansion
of air pockets within the tissue that
can cause cracking of the tissue and
just disruption of the overall
morphology
with spatial transcriptomics approaches
we highly recommend performing an RNA
Integrity assessment obtaining the Rin
value or RNA Integrity number
this helps to ensure that sample has
been optimally stored to ensure good
quality libraries can be produced
again our tissue preparation guide
provides details on how to do this
in general we found that Rin values of 7
or higher are associated with a high
degree of success
at the beginning of this talk I
mentioned that there is a strong Synergy
in combining single cell and spatial
transcriptomics approaches so I'll
quickly touch on a couple sample prep
recommendations for such an integrated
analysis
with our current spatial transcriptomics
approach which I've already talked about
we work from Frozen tissues
for researchers who are interested in an
integrated approach looking at both
single cell and spatial transcriptomics
it is possible to perform single cell
transcriptomics from a frozen sample
doing so requires isolation of nuclei as
it is not possible to isolate intact
viable cells from a flash frozen sample
with a nuclei-seq approach there are
fewer overall transcripts as the
cytoplasm is being discarded but this
does allow for the direct comparison of
single nucleus data with spatial data
from within the same tissue
although single nuclei approaches are
somewhat less sensitive for the reason I
already discussed the ability to
identify cellular subtypes is still
largely preserved you can see in this
example here two samples that were of
intact cells that were isolated from
neuronal tissue and two nuclei preps and
you can see that the overall patterns
are very similar
looking at individual cell markers from
both intact cells and from isolated
nuclei shows that in most cases
canonical markers of individual cell
types can still be detected and the cell
subtypes identified
once more our website has a number of
demonstrated protocols for the isolation
of nuclei from four single nuclei
sequencing depending on the starting
tissue type we have guides working from
tissue culture or suspension cells easy
to dissociate easy to dissociate tissues
or more complex or frozen tissues
the overall process is relatively
straightforward and there's no
requirement for dissociation of cells
before nuclei isolation
nuclei can be isolated directly either
from fresh or frozen tissue
Dr Luciano martolato now the scientific
director of the Single Cell core
laboratory at Harvard has made public a
protocol that he and his group developed
that they called the Frankenstein
protocol
this takes nuclei isolation procedures
one step further using flow or facts for
to in order to purify isolated nuclei
this protocol can be found on our
website in the customer developed
protocols section
Dr martol has also developed an
extension to this protocol called the
daughter of Frankenstein protocol which
uses gradient separation rather than
facts that protocol is available on
protocols.io
when preparing nuclei a microscopic
assessment of the nuclear membrane
Integrity can be of particular value
this slide refers to single cell attack
sequencing but the same premise holds
true for gene expression
nuclei with more intact membranes will
typically provide higher quality data
I'd like to close out this presentation
by briefly talking about informatic
approaches to integrating single cell or
single nuclei and spatial transcriptomic
data
recently there have been a number of
Publications that bring together single
cell and spatial transcriptomic
information
this sort of integrated analysis
provides even greater understanding of
the complex biology underlying processes
within tissues
the overall concept generally involves
using the transcriptomic signatures
identified for various cell types in a
single cell experiment and finding those
same signatures within the tissue in
order to identify where these cell types
exist within the context of the in-tax
tissue
here you can see a couple methods
mentioned the robust cell type
decomposition tool from Rafael irizari's
Lab at the Dana-Farber and serad from
Rao satija's Lab at the New York genome
Center
these tools can actually work with data
sets that were generated from different
tissues although from the same type of
tissue however they can be even more
powerful when being when analyzed using
data from the same tissue
a practical example of the advantage of
integrated analysis can be seen in this
paper from Main Art at all at the Johns
Hopkins
using 10x genomics's visium spatial
transcriptomics platform the researchers
looked at the dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex of the brain and they were able
to identify the key cortical layers
based on gene expression patterns
overall it was possible to identify six
cortical layers
key marker genes were used to help
Define the spatial Topography of the
overall expression in the six layer
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
from there adding single nuclei RNA
Expressions data sets
generated on the 10x genomic single cell
expression platform helped to provide
further insights as to the function of
molecularly defined cell types it was
possible to use both of these data sets
to register the Single Cell expression
patterns into spatial contacts and to
identify which cortical layers each cell
type resided Within
here's another example which involves
some of our own 10x scientists including
Dr Wyatt McDonald
in this case the same triple negative
breast cancer sample was processed with
a visium spatial transcriptomics assay
as well as our single nuclei gene
expression assay
integration of single cell and spatial
data was performed using Sarat from the
satija lab you can learn more about how
Sarat does this at the link provided in
the last bullet point here
single nuclei sequencing produced a
robust atlas of cell types from immune
cells to stromal cells and tumor cells
signatures of each of these cell types
were then used to integrate with the
spatial transcriptomic data
here we see the localization of tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes specifically T
cells in these tumor sections
pathologist annotations of the tumor
sections are seen in the panels below
appointed that the largest region
encircled in the darker green shade is
annotated as invasive carcinoma and the
blue regions were identified as immune
cells
here you can see that indeed there are T
cells within the immune compartment
however it also appears that there seems
to be some infiltration of these cells
into the tumor
when looking at B cells we see that
these cells are more isolated to the
immune compartment very few of them seem
to be invading into the tumor as we saw
with the T cells
the researchers also looked at a number
of other cell signatures in this case
we're seeing the signature for a luminal
progenitor cell type which can be seen
throughout the tissue
now unless you think this only applies
to human and mouse systems this is a
wonderful example from Montreal studying
the developing chicken heart
tissue sections from various points of
development were taken and profiled
using the visium system
similarly tissues were dissociated into
single cell suspension and analyzed
using the 10x genomic single cell
platform
this data was then integrated and
analyzed
throughout the stages of development a
number of cell types were identified to
create a diverse cell Atlas
across a developmental time course
the proportion and distribution of the
cell types changes over this
developmental time course starting with
more progenitor-based lineages in the
early stages and progressing to more
highly differentiated and mature cell
types such as cardiomyocytes in the
later stages
we can also see that there are Regional
localization of these different cell
types within the tissue architecture
as I mentioned before
the spots on our spatial transcriptomics
platform are currently 55 microns in
diameter as such one spot could contain
more than one cell or cell type
theoretically between 1 and 10 cells
typically it's more like two to four
cells
new approaches are emerging that allow
for a deconvolution of the signature
within a given spot
in this way it's possible to estimate
the total contribution of individual
cell types
this high this slide highlights a few of
these methods I'm going to show you some
data from a couple of these approaches
and M Fred from alexandrina's gueva's
Lab at the broad and Spotlight from
Holger Heinz Lab at the crg in Barcelona
and I'm frag is being used here to
deconvolute the signatures within the
hindbrain of an adult Mouse
specifically in the left panel the
spatial distribution of parvalbumin and
interneurons is being identified and on
the right it is signatures for purkinje
cells
both of these panels are colored by a
temperature scale which shows the
fraction of each spot that contains
signatures for that cell type
in this example nietoidal from the hind
lab we're looking at the tumor immune
microenvironment
in the left panel you can see that a
number of cell types were identified
using single cell transcriptomic
analysis
for this analysis over 500 cells from
more than 200 patients across 13
different cancers were analyzed
in the right panel you see the
contribution of each of the cell types
to the various different cancers
taking this information
Nieto at all applied the hind lab's
Spotlight pipeline to deconvolute each
spot of a vision transcriptomic assay
in the left panel
on the left side of the left panel
you will see the spots colored by gene
expression signature so we have fibrotic
tissue her2 or ESR status
in that same panel on the right you see
each spot colored by the overall
contribution of the individual cell
types in fact if you zoom in you will
see that each spot now is represented by
a miniaturized pie chart which shows the
contribution of each cell type
this is a wonderful way of visualizing
the data and understanding what the
component or the contribution is of
individual cell types
I hope that you found this presentation
to be informative
for anyone wishing to get started with
or take their single cell and spatial
transcriptomics research to the next
level please take advantage of the
numerous resources on our website
further if you have any support
questions please visit our support
website or reach out to us at support
10xgenomics.com
I'd like to thank you very much from
Team 10x and wish you a wonderful day